[Musique]
c'est aussi notre habileté politique ce
matin c'est jean pierre raffarin bonjour
jean pierre raffarin ancien premier
ministre président de l' ong leader pour
la paix et président de la fondation
prospective et innovation merci beaucoup
bonjour nous ce matin on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par julien lécuyer
de la voix du nord bonjour julien
bonjour oriane bonjour monsieur premier
ministre bonjour bonjour à nos amis du
nord
écoute mais qu'on commence évidemment
par la crise sanitaire jean pierre
raffarin jean castex qui doit s'exprimer
une nouvelle fois ce soir à 18 heures
sur la clé sanitaires et tout porte à
croire qu'il y aura des mesures
restrictives au moins dans les hautes
france et en ile de france
est-ce qu emmanuel macron a trop tardé à
remettre en place ce confinement dans
ces régions
personnellement je ne le pense pas mais
vous savez ce qui me frappe c'est que
cette situation elle est complètement
inédite
tous les jours il ya une surprise on
avait ce vaccin en lutte on était en
guerre et puis d'un seul coup ce vaccin
créé des petits très différent on avait
et on avait un virus qui quitte ce qui
se multiplient et qui devient de plus en
plus contagieux on est dans une
situation difficile où notre partenaire
numéro à l'allemagne qui suspend le
vaccin on est obligé de suivre nos
partenaires européens
on est dans une situation où l'imprévu
domine donc je trouve qu'il ya beaucoup
d'arrogance dans la vie politique
beaucoup de gens qui disent et qui
critique de l'opération un peu un peu
partout dans la société
la france a toujours été difficile à
gouverner mais aujourd'hui face à une
guerre de l'imprévu qui est une guerre
permanente c'est particulièrement sur
celle ci quand on est en guerre on
discute pas tous les jours le rôle des
officiers on a souvent qualifié le
président de maîtres des horloges
or lui même a dit d'ailleurs en début de
semaine que le vrai maître du temps
c'est elle c'était le virus est ce qui a
pas quand même un enjeu essentiel dans
cette gestion c'est celui de la
réélection de d'emmanuel macron on sait
pas l'enjeu du président l'enjeu du
président siad sortir de la crise a
naturellement qu'il devra s'occuper des
élections présidentielles
mais aujourd'hui le problème que nous
avons c'est de sortir de la crise et
donc le problème que nous avons c'est
d'avoir une organisation qui nous
permettent de faire face à la crise de
l'hôpital parce que finalement on a un
problème de lits d'hôpitaux et donc il
faut gérer cette crise là et à côté on a
été gérée elle est venue avec ça on voit
bien qu'on est dans une situation où on
manque de lits donc c'est très difficile
parce que cette crise elle est
exceptionnelle donc on peut pas avoir
non plus des équipements pour
l'exceptionnel on a des équipements pour
l'habituelle pour le normal donc là on
est dans des situations extrêmement
pathologique et donc il est clair que
c'était très difficile à agir et c'est
très difficile aujourd'hui à s'ingérer
la bastille nation de faire don de faire
un nom monsieur même premier ministre
que ce problème de lits a été a été
pointé du doigt
or visiblement les services de
réanimation sont toujours extrêmement
saturé est ce que le gouvernement n'a
pas suffisamment mis l'accent sur la
création dit probablement qu'il ya des
insuffisances et qui date d'avant ce
gouvernement bien sûr mais regardez
est-ce qu'on reste qu'on serait mis en
italie ce qu'on serait mieux en espagne
se serait mis en angleterre est ce qu'on
serait mieux ou est-ce qu'on serait
mieux
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui c'est
extrêmement difficile donc
mesure où nous sommes en crise et en
crise on se bat contre l'ennemi l'ennemi
c'est le virus c'est par le gouvernement
et l'union nationale devrait être dans
cette situation là il faut penser à
toutes les françaises et les français
qui sont très inquiet qui ne connaissent
pas les réponses à leurs questions
et pourquoi ils ne connaissent pas parce
qu'on ne connaît pas non plus et donc on
est dans une situation aujourd'hui de
combat et il ne faut pas naturellement
s'en prendre aux combattants c'est ce
que ceux qui s'en prennent aux
combattants se sont aussi les élus
locaux qu'on entend beaucoup critiqué
les décisions du gouvernement
je pense qu'il ya en effet des
incompréhensions je priais je suis
d'accord avec tout ce qui est fait un
jeu je devais me faire vacciner là pas
aujourd'hui et d'ailleurs
mais je te mets père maxime est prêt je
suis reporter parce que en étant
suspension donc déjà aussi géraud non il
ya aussi beaucoup de désagréments dans
cette affaire mais je ne cherche pas
dans une période aussi difficile que ça
je ne cherche pas un fragiliser nos
autorités et notamment notre premier
ministre qui fait un travail est très
très difficile et il faut respecter la
difficulté de parler du vaccin vraiment
sur les élus locaux et la
décentralisation jetons puisque ça pose
aussi ses questions elle les pauses les
pôles clairement puisque l'épidémie pour
vous elle a consacré quoi le centralisme
où la nécessité du d'un peu plus de
décentralisation c'est que xavier
bertrand par exemple a plaidé pour que
la santé reviennent aux régions c'est
pas du tout point de vue du gouvernement
qui veut garder cette ce domaine de
compétence c'est quoi votre position moi
je suis d'accord avec xavier bertrand
sur ces sujets là je trouve que c'est
une des points que j'ai deux distances
avec le gouvernement le gouvernement
voit la décentralisation comme un
partenariat faut que le maire travaille
avec le préfet heureusement qu'ils
travaillent ensemble
heureusement qu'il faut qu'ils aient des
idées travailler ensemble c'est
maintenant la décentralisation c'est des
libertés en échange de responsabilités
et donc je crois qu'il faut donner des
libertés en matière de santé aux régions
mais aussi leur donner des
responsabilités mais parce
qu'aujourd'hui au fond l'élu il est dans
une situation où il manque de liberté et
puis manque de responsabilité aussi et
donc la décentralisation
ce n'est pas donné aujourd'hui
d je dirais des transferts de
compétences seulement c'est de donner
des libertés contre des responsabilités
mais le rize la liberté de la santé
c'est quelque chose de tout leur talent
au risque qui est pointé du doigt par le
gouvernement c'est d'avoir une santé qui
fonctionne à plusieurs vitesses au sein
du lieu du territoire
c'est bien que vous croyez que c'est pas
déjà le cas oui mais vous êtes soigné
partout tout le temps pareil locale donc
il mais c'est pas ça qu'il faut résoudre
d'abord avant de transférer auprès des
riant non je pense que l'état doit avoir
un rôle dans la santé
l'état doit avoir un rôle d'équilibré
doit avoir un rôle d' de péréquation et
donc il ya des choses qui doivent être
faits pour la justice territoriale
mais l'initiative la responsabilité vous
savez en avance que par la
responsabilité pourquoi nos hôpitaux
sont aux ordres aujourd'hui tellement
exemplaire c'est parce qu'ils assument
leurs responsabilités et au fond ils
n'attendent pas que on leur donne de
paris et des instructions pour prendre
en charge les problèmes qu'ils ont face
à eux quotidiennement c'est la
responsabilité qui est la clé et la
décentralisation
ce n'est pas le partenariat c'est le
transfert de responsable mais comment
vous expliquez que ça ne se fasse pas
vous vous êtes à l'origine des dernières
grandes lois de décentralisation
emmanuel macron il avait promis une
nouvelle décentralisation voc la loi
cadre et elle a du mal à arriver et
hervé morin qui était sur ce plateau
hier le président la région normandie
dib est ce qu'on voit c'est très faible
est ce que c'est aussi votre avis bien
sûr que c'est faible parce que
aujourd'hui vous avez la santé il faut
reparler descente raison de la santé on
est toujours sur les routes nationales
ya 30 ans n'était encore sur le
transfert des routes nationales donc je
vois bien que dans ce texte il ya des
choses qui sont intéressantes mais
globalement on ne traite pas les deux
sujets qui devraient être au coeur de la
décentralisation la santé et l'emploi et
pour qu'on n'arrive pas décentralisé
mais bien parce que globe est toujours
mission face parce que le jacobinisme et
dominant que tous ceux qui sont dans le
pouvoir central ne veulent pas donner
leur responsabilité et chaos total on
est toujours ne les girondins un peu
minoritaire dans dans ce pays mais quand
vous pensez qu'on donne aux régions la
responsabilité du soutien on entre aux
entreprises donc si une politique
d'exportation si une politique
d'innovation
c'est une politique d'investissements on
te confier des responsabilités à la
région mais on lui confie pas la
responsabilité du chômage
l'emploi il reste nationale donc d'un
côté ils ont le cerveau droit qui
fonctionne pour l'entreprise de l'autre
côté le cerveau gauche pour l'emploi ne
fonctionne pas au niveau régional donc
ça c'est une pathologie l'emploi et la
santé devraient être des grands
chantiers de décentralisation
aujourd'hui donc la loi cadet est encore
une occasion manquée seul but c'est que
c'est une loi minimale on va revenir
avec sa wii puisque le président de la
république a donc annoncé pendant
quelques jours la suspension de la
vaccination avec astrazeneca
aujourd'hui on devrait avoir enfin
l'avis de l'agencé européenne du
médicament pour savoir si on peut
reprendre et ce qu'il a eu raison de
suspendre en amont de cette décision ne
peut pas faire autrement
l'espagne l'italie l'allemagne les pays
bas et alors nous on est autant on est
tous temps entouré parce qu'il ya une
solidarité
mais vous imaginez si on a un problème
grec qui qui qui peut se poser la
responsabilité qu'il peut avoir de jouer
seul et de jouer en séance situation
combien de décalage par applaudissent
qu'une véritable plus grande attendre de
vacciner alors que visiblement le nombre
de cas de thrombose
relever est très faible je ne suis pas
un médecin
donc je me méfie aujourd'hui de toutes
les informations qui peuvent circuler
donc je on a besoin dans ces domaines là
d'une autorité et c'est à l'autorité
européenne de se prononcer à partir du
moment où vous avez des grands pays
comme l'allemagne l'italie ou l'espagne
qui met en cause quelque chose c'est à
l'autorité européenne de se prononcer et
donc je trouve que le le président
respecte une sorte d'abord sa conviction
européenne c'est au niveau européen
qu'il faut tenait cette coordination
le président choisit ce cap-là de
l'europe et je la trouve ensuite dans
cette situation là il est clair que nous
avons besoin aujourd'hui d'une cohérence
scientifique qu'ils puissent s'exprimer
et cette cohérence c'est à l' agence
européenne de la dette mais est-ce que
l'unité européenne elle existe tant que
ça sur la végétation riche et le
d'allemagne qui parlait de s'allier avec
israël on a vu la slovaquie et la ronde
et la hongrie qui ont reçu des doses de
vaccin russe la pologne qui parle de
commandes avec la chine à ce que l'union
européenne allait pas en train de se
fracturer sur cette stratégie vaccinale
c'est le grand danger mais ça va bien au
delà c'est qu'aujourd'hui le monde est
en train de s'organiser de manière
bipolaire entre la chine et les états
unis
cette tension là elle est une tension
qui est en train de dominer tout est
bien autre chose que la santé
l'intelligence artificielle tout un
grand nombre de sujets
l'approvisionnement en matières
premières
donc cette bataille-là qui s'annonce
entre la chine et les états unis n'y a
qu'une seule réponse pour nous c'est
l'europe
donc si l'europe se fragilise c'est nous
qui pouvons sortir de l'histoire
la france qui a participé à l'histoire
peut très bien aujourd'hui se trouvait
spectatrice de l'histoire et tout ça
c'est parce que au fond le monde est en
train de devenir bipolaire est la seule
chance que nous avons d'exister c'est
que l'europe affirme sa souveraineté que
l'europe soit en bonne relation avec les
etats-unis en bonnes relations avec la
chine avec les des distances mais
qu'elle affirme son indépendance qu'elle
redevienne gaullienne d'une certaine
manière et qu'elle puisse avoir une
stratégie
donc tout ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
est en effet assez désolant est assez
inquiétant donc je ne suis pas pour dire
que le l'europe aujourd'hui est
satisfaisante non mais je pense qu'il
faut continuer les efforts et donc il
faut continuer les hanter ses erreurs
selon selon vous l'union européenne
des lenteurs
oeuvres d'edith des divergences de
stratégie les lenteurs c'est la
démocratie et ça il faut accepter que on
a choisi la démocratie on est content de
ce choix il faut continuer dans ce choix
est naturellement le choix démocratique
il est quand même plus lent que le joug
autoritaire
non que vous faites à un théâtre un
théâtre avec un auditorium à poitiers
entre le jour vous le décidez et le jour
vous le faites il faut dix ans il ya
beaucoup de pays dans le monde où en un
an et demi c'est fait on may et mais il
n'y a pas les recours il n'y a pas tous
de la pelade la place des citoyens donc
nous devons il faut accepter le temps
dans ce qui est dangereux aujourd'hui
dans l'europe
c'est cette incapacité à se rassembler
sur des grandes crises pour pouvoir
avoir une seule voie et à avoir une
efficacité au service de cette voie est
donc là on a eu une certaine forme de
cohérence c'est bien mais on n'a pas
forcément une certaine efficacité comme
on le voudrait mais ne je fais confiance
sur cette idée de souveraineté à
quelqu'un comme thierry breton qui
connaît bien le sujet notamment sur
l'intelligence artificielle sur les
technologies qui sont au coeur la
révolution digitale est au coeur de
notre avenir
tout comme les questions de santé et là
je pense qu'il ya une vraie volonté
européenne pour la première fois de
penser à cette idée de souveraineté
européenne qui doit s'articuler avec une
soudaine et les bretons qui est devenu
le monsieur vaccin est ce que les
vaccins aujourd'hui selon vous sont
devenus une arme diplomatique
bien sûr bien sûr on voit bien que la
russie la chine essaie de développer des
relations internationales autour de 7,2
cette logique là donc bien sûr c'est une
arme diplomatique mais je pense que
c'est une arme diplomatique pour un
temps le fond de la faire si vous voulez
c'est que nous nous sommes dans une
compétition internationale aujourd'hui
extrêmement fier envoyer la réaction des
des anglais sur sur leur propre vaccin
on voit qu'il y a il ya d une forme
d'agressivité international de nervosité
internationale aujourd'hui extrêmement
dangereux doit hausser le ton vis-à-vis
de bruce johnson justement sur ce
je pense que l'europe doit affirmer en
effet ces combats et donc je pense que
sur ce sujet il faut remobiliser la
l'opinion publique européenne et que le
que le peuple européen
les peuples européens c'est un pluriel
puisse à sentir qu'ils sont défendus par
leurs organisations européennes et donc
ça de ce point de vue là je pense qu'il
faut expliquer à monsieur johnson
il ya des choses qui sont inacceptables
si c'était dans ses rapports continental
pour moi dans un rapport de voisinage
mais quand les européens le voile et les
les britanniques se faire vacciner à
tour de bras est ce que ça donne pas un
point aux eurosceptiques ça ça peut
donner un point mais on voit bien que il
ya eu beaucoup de difficultés au début
dans la crise ils ont un nombre de morts
particulièrement pathologique donc je
pense qu'il faut être conscient que pour
nous l'essentiel c'est aujourd'hui la
stratégie européenne moi vraiment je
suis frappée je vois que vous avez le
livre de la fondation je suis frappé par
aujourd'hui ces tensions internationales
qui voyez vous voyez là le le président
mbaye donne qui traite de tueurs
monsieur poutine monsieur poutine qui
rappelle son ambassadeur
tout ça ce sont des des frictions très
très lourde et on ouvre on est en train
de rapprocher
poutine et si jean ping ensemble donc on
est en train de construire un pôle
autoritaire dans le monde qui va était
extraordinairement puissant qu'il ya
beaucoup de de risque dans tout cela on
a un continent africain'' réservoir peut
aller jusqu'où pour vous tous a abattu
tout ça c'est évident qu'il peut y avoir
un moment ou un autre
une explosion qui est d'abord une
explosion politique on a vu la guerre
des droits de l'homme ou des droïdes les
droits de l'homme on a bu la guerre des
droits de douane on voit de la guerre
qui s'annonce sur l'intelligence
artificielle et au total peut-être un
jour une action militaire il vous savez
on a vu des guerres partir sur des
erreurs partir sur abc mist sur sur
l'avenir de ces de ses relations
internationales si vous voulez je vois
que des forces négatives
aujourd'hui dans le monde excepté une
que j'appelle la planète isation c'est à
dire que toutes les jeunesses du monde
entier ont fait de la planète un objet
politique contrairement génération
d'avant on a parlé de la mondialisation
et la mondialisation ct kwh c'étaient
les échanges et c'était la performance
économique
aujourd'hui quand on parle aux jeunes
mais vous
aux jeunes chinois au jeune brésilien
aux jeunes américains ils vous disent la
même chose l'essentiel aujourd'hui c'est
de protéger la planète
c'est une humanisation de la planète
parce que protéger la planète c'est
protéger l'humanité
donc il ya ce bout de consensus
aujourd'hui qui est en train
d'apparaître
si vous regardez le discours de ces jean
ping quand ils signent l'accord de paris
et le discours de du président byden
quand il revient dans l'accord de paris
c'est à peu près le même discours ça
ressemble à ce que disait jacques chirac
à johannesbourg la maison brison bull
il faut protéger la planète et donc il y
a on ne fait pas la paix si on n'a pas
un consensus le consensus aujourd'hui il
peut se faire sur la protection de la
planète s'est pas encore fait il ya
encore beaucoup d'écart mais ce qui est
très important c'est que les jeunes du
monde entier les femmes les sociétés
civiles sont de plus en plus aligné sur
cette perspective donc la planéte
isation ça peut être une humanisation de
la mondialisation
et ça je pense que c'est quelque chose
qui est important parce que sans
consensus
il y aura pas de paix sans consensus n'y
a pas de démarche pour une gouvernance
internationale la planète isation c'est
ce qui est en train d'arriver
on fait de la planète un objet politique
et donc ça il ya une lueur d'espoir
aujourd'hui c'est un consensus à table
tout le reste on ne voit que des
tensions et donc vous pouvez avoir sur
taïwan vous pouvez en version beaucoup
de sujets et notamment les batailles sur
les matières premières en afrique
beaucoup de sujets qui tourne mal à la
sécurité alès de l'europe quelque chose
aussi de très fragile
donc on voit qu'on a des des régions qui
sont aujourd'hui très menacée par des
déséquilibres majeurs et auquel cas il
est important
d'une part que l'europe soit une force
très organisés que d'autre part les
démocraties puissent ensemble travailler
pour se renforcer car on voit de nos
démocraties on arrive on a vu le
capitole on a vu les gilet jaune on voit
bien que nos démocraties sont très
différentes mais elles se parlent peu on
parle pas beaucoup avec le japon avec la
corée avec
les démocraties du sud il faut pouvoir
mes racines ne sont pas fragiliser elles
sont fragilisées et il faut qu'elles
travaillent ensemble pour se renforcer
baden a annoncé un sommet des
démocraties
je pense que c'est très important que
les démocraties ce must parce que les
régimes autoritaires sont très
importants aujourd'hui dans le monde et
qu'on est obligé par parler avec les
régimes autoritaires
on ne peut pas se contenter de mesures
brutales d'exclusion on est obligé de
parier sur une plaine il faut qu'on vive
ensemble donc on est obligé de se parler
mais se parler ça veut dire qu'il faut
accepter le rapport de force et le
rapport de force pour les démocraties il
faut le renforcer vous parlez des
régimes autoritaires mais vous avez
plusieurs sondages qui montrent que la
tentation autoritaire grimpe y compris
chez chez les jeunes est ce que vous
voyez cette es ce que vous avez cette
inquiétude même vis-à-vis de la france
bien sûr bien sûr qu'on voit bien on
voit bien que les populismes on voit
bien mais la leçon des états unis a été
très intéressante dans cette dernière
présidentielle
qu'est ce qui a sauvé les états unis du
régime autoritaire de trump c'est la
participation électorale monsieur trump
fait plus de 4 millions de voix que la
fin de son mandat au début de son mandat
donc il a séduit des américains mais la
participation électorale fait que byden
à 80 millions c'est les gens qui vont
tous voter
et quand je vois que nous on était deux
fois moins de 25% dans nos municipal
tout ça je me dis vraiment s'il n'y a
pas de participation électorale y a pas
de démocratie mais comme bientôt fait
pour amener la ramener les français aux
jeunes et il faut sans doute parler des
sujets qui les concernent directement
donc par exemple la planète isation par
exemple les g de lait que
l'écologie mais en fait l'écologie dans
une vision assez globale y compris un
peu long voilà c'est d'avoir un horizon
politique et une perspective la
politique c'est une question de vision
et donc la vision politique c'est la
protection de la planète
mais je pense que il faut vraiment que
les démocraties se parlent vous voyez il
ya des temps les démocraties sont très
différentes
l'allemagne et la france sont très
différentes comme gouvernance entre le
pré la république et la chancelière les
le régime fédéral on a beaucoup de
différents quand vous regardez
la israël avec la partie sur la
proportionnelle généralisée quand vous
regardez la corée du sud vous voyez que
il ya un certain nombre de démocraties
qui sont performants dans un certain
nombre de domaines
je pense que les démocraties doivent se
parler pour son système proportionnel à
les relancer
excusez-moi ariane c'est le on a un
grand débat sur la proportionnelle mais
plus largement sur une revitalisation de
la démocratie ça doit passer par la
proportionnelle selon vous moi je ne le
pense pas cm il faut être ouvert sur ces
questions là moi je pense qu'il ya deux
prendre logique démocratique à la
logique de l'alternance
quand une démocratie c'est là où vous
pouvez changer vos dirigeants
la france elle donne des pouvoirs à une
équipe pendant cinq ans cependant cinq
ans l'équipe au pouvoir allait pouvoir
et elle peut exercer et au bout de cinq
ans vous pouvez les changer c'est nous
on est dans une logique de l'alternance
à côté ça israël par exemple ils sont
dans une logique de la représentativité
toutes les tendances sont présentes à la
knesset et donc vous avez une
proportionnelle mais là vous avez des
difficultés de gouvernements souvent
vous avez naturellement le poids des
minorités qui font les majorités est
petit et pèse considérablement
je préfère la logique de l'alternance
analogique de la rue manque à ce qu'ils
font ce qu'il faut dans le pôle le
pouvoir parlementaire il n'est pas lié à
ça le pouvoir parlementaire idée liée à
ce que la législative aller de fait le
lendemain des présidentielles et que le
président fait le député s'est énervé ça
ça c'est un rêve pour moi c'est une
erreur
c'est pour ça que personnellement je
serais pour un retour du mandat de
députée pour un mandat de quatre ans on
pourrait dire que l'idéal pour moi ce
serait des midterm parce que les
français et ils disent acceptent mal de
cinq ans durant sans avoir rien à dire
parce que pendant cinq ans il ya une
majorité un président dont clairement
l'idée de françois bayrou de remettre
sur la table la proportionnelle vous
visiez tous plus ou moins
moi je suis je préférerais soit démis
turn des législatives tous les tous les
quatre ans mais a à mi mandat
présidentiel mais s'assure que ça
n'arriverait à supprimer le droit
dissolution du président ce qui est un
élément essentiel de notre constitution
donc dans ce cas là il faut ramener le
mandat des députés à quatre ans pour que
le député soit élu par lui-même qu'il
ait sa propre crédibilité sa propre
légitimité et qu' on est un débat
politique et que on est des coalitions
et que éventuellement
des cohabitations la cohabitation sap a
été un drame quand ça a été en france
donc moi je ne suis pas opposé à ce
qu'il y ait de la cohabitation pour cela
il faut réduire le mandat des députés de
cinq à quatre ans et il nous reste deux
minutes jean pierre raffarin on va dire
un mot de ce sondage ifop julien un
sondage ifop
un de plus après celui d'harris
interactive qui évoque un resserrement
du duel entre eux emmanuel macron et
marine le pen au second tour de la
présidentielle qui atterrirait à 53 %
contre 47 et ce qu'il y à un péril pour
emmanuel macron et comment doit-il
réagir
moi je ne crois pas qu'aujourd'hui il ya
un péril je ne crois pas que marine le
pen est vraiment progressé aujourd'hui
elle profite du fait qu'elle est la
seule adversaire crédible pour le second
tour d'emmanuel macron donc elle est
dans une situation de dire qu'à droite
la personne de crédible c'est que pour
le moment la situation n'est pas tel
quel mais un candidat au deuxième tour
donc madame le pen profite de cette
situation disons tête l'anti thèse et
l'antithèse un statut dans le pays
mais le jour où on aura des candidats
qu'ils occuperont la scène je crois
qu'elle sera mais fragilisée donc
personnellement je suis évidemment pour
le front républicain je suivrai
évidemment pourquoi un peu tous les
extrémistes fonds puisse toujours se
mobilisent et que tous les modérés
tempéré de ce pays se rassemblent contre
les extrémistes extrémistes de gauche où
l'extrémiste de droite
donc je pense qu'il faut veiller à ce
que il y ait ce front républicain dont
chacun fera ce qu'il veut mais pour le
moment là où nous en sommes je crois que
la situation est très artificielle pour
vous dire mon sentiment je crois que
aujourd'hui pour emmanuel macron la
probabilité de la victoire et est
aujourd'hui tout à fait accessible et
que on verra la manière dont on sort de
cette crise du comice est ça qui sera
déterminant c'est la manière dont on
sortira le bilan mais je sais c'est sur
le coup vite que les choses se jouent de
mon point de vue est que le président
apparaîtra je pense comme quelqu'un de
fort et de responsables je crois en
revanche il ya un problème pour les
législatives la majorité présidentielle
n'est pas organisé je trouve que la
structure présidentielle n'est pas
puissante
je crois qu'on peut gagner une élection
sans parti jusqu'à l'avait déjà montré
emmanuel marque en laquelle je crois
qu'on ne peut pas être réélu sans une
organisation jusqu'à créer l'udf chirac
a fait l'ump
il faut une famille politique structuré
et aujourd'hui le président est un peu
seul au front et il n'y a pas derrière
une femme âgée d'une idée il est des
mots sur ce que veut dire extrémistes de
gauche les extrémistes de droite c'est
qu'ils les extrémistes de gauche pour
vous bah je pense qu'il est clair que ne
le lie à toute une série de dans la
france insoumise de propositions qui
sont inacceptables par rapport même aux
principes démocratiques ça veut dire que
jean luc mélenchon marine le pen vous
les mettez sur le même plan je ne les
met pas sur le même plan je ne met pas
sur le même plan je parle pas du tout
mes genoux mais je ne ferai rien pour
favoriser l'extrême gauche dans mon pays
donc je vous le dis comme je le pense
aujourd'hui il faut défendre la
république et il nous avons besoin de
valeurs
je vous en prend pas en parlant du
shérif et donc en parlant de la planète
isation je pense que ce qu'il faut c'est
qu'on ait quelques valeurs qu'ils soient
des repères la république
c'est ce qu'on a inventé pour que les
gens ne se battent pas l'adversaire
c'est la bataille l'adversaire c'est la
division dames et hier c'est la violence
l'ennemi c'est la violence s'étendant
jeu et cette république ali
extraordinairement fragile il faut la
renforcer il faut travailler notre
république et c'est ça notre valeur la
république à l'intérieur la planète
isation l'extérieur et ce sera le mot de
la fin est justement de la
mondialisation à la plaine et isation
c'est le titre de ce rapport de la
fondation prospective et innovation qui
s'intitule shérif en hommage à un poids
devant ses élèves
oui rené monory c'était le président de
cette fondation jeu le président depuis
une quinzaine d'années les rené monory
était un homme très fort qu'a présidé
cette grande institution est
merveilleuse institutions tels le sénat
qui préside aussi le département de la
vienne
on l'appelait nous les amis les cas les
collaborateurs de roy démoli en appeler
le chi risque parce qu'il arrivait
c'était passé il s'était passé diplôme
qui s'imposaient c'était pas la
technocratie
c'était son énergie et sa bonne volonté
et merci beaucoup vers sigean bercy
avant d'avoir été notre invité regarde
la une de la voix du nord
et c'est évidemment leur tous confinés
nom et pas de quelle est la même en
scène c'est la question sera ça ce soir
mais on faisait penser à rien je vois de
bertrand a fait du bon travail
[Musique]